foreign
Slayer
how are you doing
hey Chris hey that girl
hey M why no tears of the Kingdom videos
uh because I've been sick
so I'm trying to keep my stress levels
to a minimum or else it's going to get
worse and then it's gonna take even
longer for me to heal
[Music]
yeah it's a monster May stream a rare
one
yeah I apologize for being uh absent for
a while but I I just I had to get better
first I'm still not better technically
but it's getting it's getting better
symptoms are getting less annoying
I'm still waiting for a blood test
for the results I should say
but we will see
at least I uh I'm not as tired anymore
that's the
that's the biggest
biggest difference
hey hero thanks
yeah it's been a while
uh let me just uh this is such a great
game
I really love this one I also love ages
but I don't remember ages as well so
instead of embarrassing myself on stream
on that game I will pick up pick up that
one after this one
I'm just happy that they are finally
because the Oracle games have been
they've not been very accessible
which I I really don't understand maybe
it's got something to do with Capcom
because they're they they technically
made it
but you know
yeah this opening is very short
it's just like everybody's dancing
having a good time
and then we can immediately go for The
Sword and the first dungeon
yeah
since when have you been doing live
chats well I've I've done some live
stuff quite a bit before
but this summer has just not been a
great time for me
this has been a bad summer
not just because of the weather but also
because of circumstances
Wind Waker and Twilight Princess I
already did Twilight Princess a whole
playthrough
[Music]
and Ocarina of Time I don't know if I
did windbreaker
I was planning to do Majora's Mask at
some point but
I don't know then tears of the Kingdom
content got in the way I guess
I don't remember it's been a while
um romalek I prefer ages between the two
I think both are great games they
complement each other very well
like from what I get I played Aegis
first back in the day because they said
it was more puzzle oriented
and seasons was more combat oriented
it's not that I'm necessarily better at
puzzles than combat but I don't know
I guess I just chose the blue one
Arco that was excited for these to be
added because there there are a few
Zelda games that I haven't played yet
oh yeah well they just were not very
accessible
like
I think they got released of course
originally for the Game Boy Color but
I don't even remember it might have been
for the DS or something but other than
that you didn't have any options except
you know emulators
I have the mark of the hero even though
that should not be the case because this
is supposed to take place after a link
to the past and at the end of the link
to the past the Triforce was wished upon
which means it goes away and becomes one
again
I don't know
the whole downfall timeline is a mess
anyway
I do think uh ages definitely has a
better villain I think Veron was more
interesting than General on ox
or general unox as we used to call him
Point Crow hasn't posted in ages well
that in his case that might have
something to do with the whole problem
he got with copyright strikes and
thank you Mission Slayer
uh don't worry there will be content on
the way again
I guess like in a month or so when my
health has completely returned uh
I I'm I am working on stuff sparingly
I'm about eight pages into the script of
my next video I've already done some
some captures
so but I just try to minimize my amount
of the amount of time behind my computer
as much as humanly possible because
sitting down
is much more uncomfortable than standing
up plus it's just better for my health
if I move a lot more so I go on a lot of
walks and
I try to eat as healthy as I possibly
can
or else the symptoms are just gonna get
worse and worse
or at least they're gonna stay the same
but yeah this this year has been
particularly bad I don't know why
I did have this problem last year in the
summer as well
but I remember it being a lot less
hectic and a lot less or a lot less
extreme I should say
and I think it also went away a lot
quicker
I still don't know exactly what causes
it could be an allergic reaction to
something or it does always coincide
with my hay fever so maybe that has
something to do with it because last
year it started in
early June and ended in like halfway
through July the I was finally
starting to feel better this year
I mean we're already almost in August
like I said the it is getting better but
it's not I'm not 100 just yet
look at these special effects yeah let
me know if the sound levels are are good
because the these old
8-bit music Q like music tracks and and
sound effects can be they cut through a
mix pretty easily
yeah okay cool
just making sure
it's empire
what is she doing in a different realm
or country
no one knows
all right I'm just just gonna skip
through it
yeah yeah I'm the I'm the big hero who
can save everyone
I just want to play already
so I think the first dungeon is up here
but I need this sword to cut away the
bush
because of the zonai
yeah audio is something because I cannot
hear what you guys hear
unless I go to my own stream but then
you get Echoes and all that kind of
uh I don't know if I can get the sword
right away
or if I have to go to talk to the no I
do have to get the sword first because
I think the maku tree doesn't talk to
you you have to open the door
the hero's cave this is very similar to
Link's Awakening
of course you cannot fight anything
[Music]
I'm always struggling to decide if I
want to use the d-pad for these type of
games so I just use the
analog stick even though that's kind of
counter-intuitive but
it's more comfortable for the thumb
yeah the Horan Village Theme is really
good
I'm defenseless
[Music]
but yeah my next uh my upcoming video
about tears of the kingdom is gonna be
about the upheaval and what it is and
what caused it
foreign
[Music]
into another video which is about the
zonai shika connections
[Music]
oh thanks Adam
have a good one thanks for dropping by
yeah I also hope that they will remake
this one as well
although if I had to choose I prefer
just a brand new
entry just a brand new 2D cell game one
that nobody has played before
but yeah if they remake these games it's
fine as well
I know not everyone can still deal with
these kinds of graphics
some people just want to see it
in a more modern modern setting
but since they released them here now I
feel like
the chance of that happening has
diminished
I don't know like I said maybe it has
something to do with the fact that they
were developed by Capcom and not
necessarily the main Zelda team so maybe
they
they co-owned this these two games
I I'm not sure if that's true
but it is weird if they do remake Link's
Awakening and they don't do these ones
because they're practically the same
when it comes to the graphics and the
the feeling
the wooden sword
which doesn't break
but a deco stick does
oh yeah you have to poke the
yeah I also prefer the Oracle games over
Link's Awakening I do think Link's
Awakening story is more
interesting more unique
but the gameplay is not really as good I
think
what's to be done monster maze
with the seasons and chaos
the land is robbed of the very essence
of nature
draining all my mic can you save din in
my stead well you're a tree I mean even
if you could like what would he have
done if I wasn't around he's kind of
stuck stuck in one place
I sense evil on the Northern Peak
oh yeah
oh yeah this is the game with uh
subrosia
I always mix that I thought Aegis was
the one with subrosia but it's this one
I should know that I have I've finished
this game at least five times by now
because the story of the the Oracle
games is pretty stock
let's just get the eight things
but the gameplay itself and the little
stories here and there is just really
fun
oh did I choose
why does it even give me the option
it's the owl over all over again
shower it repeat it
new
plot twist he was an ant all the all
along could have moved but he just
didn't want to
that fasting
technically we got kind of
the ants
in tears of the Kingdom those walking
trees
not really but
that scared the crap out of me the first
time that it happened
I was like what the heck is going on
why are the trees coming after me
oh
I forgot what the the name of that enemy
is something evergreen or something ever
mean
it's like a pun on the word Evergreen I
think
hey nebula yeah thanks um
slowly but surely I'm doing better
just take some time
I like the female tree that falls in
love with you more yeah
[Music]
the gnarled root
I like the Boss music in the in the
Oracle games
[Music]
damn
thank you
okay I need the Ember seeds for this
[Music]
thank you
Mike and negative that's a great name
return light to the online yeah I know
what
is there another door here oh there is
gotta go down
yeah I have great memories of this game
I remember so vividly the time and place
and and the circumstances
I remember it being
I think either spring or summer oh this
was this was the exit
uh yeah it was like spring or
summer I think
and I was on MSN which most of you
probably don't even know what that is
anymore because it's really old
and my parents called me because they
went to the city to pick up the game for
me I don't even remember why that I
guess they had to go into the city as
like to do something else and I told him
I wanted the game and I was on the
Amazon chatting with other people
and then
my parents called me which one do you
want the blue one or the red one
and since I had chosen Pokemon Red back
in the day I was like you know what I'm
gonna mix it up I'm gonna go with blue
foreign
so maybe it wasn't because it was a
puzzle game it was just because I like
the color blue
[Music]
let's see this game on GB
let me see real quick I'm so bad at
multitasking
first Monster May stream for me anyway
oh well welcome I don't stream very
often I know
I kind of just do it on a whim most of
the time
[Music]
but yeah let's stream today it's also
because I've been inactive for a while
and I I just I cannot even though I
stand fully behind the fact that I'm not
doing too much content right now
uh I I cannot help but feel guilty where
I'm like God damn man people are
expecting me to upload stuff and I
really really don't want to let people
down
oh Tyler thank you so much I don't know
I don't know if anyone taught you this
but
do Zelda's tears wait let me get in
closer I cannot see very well oh
the chat window is too far away I don't
know if anyone thought this
I thought this not taught this
but do Zelda's tears have like a power
to them tears of the Kingdom Zelda
created memories with their tears and an
age of Calamity she dropped her tears on
tariko's eye
which made it summon future Heroes yeah
I guess although I still think it's a
bit of a at least in the in age of
Calamity I thought it was a
kind of a lazy pluck device
just like oh now her tears are suddenly
Magic
but uh I guess Dragon Tears are more
powerful
foreign
I like turtles
uh I
think they're okay
[Music]
sea turtles yes
my fiancee has a
phobia for turtles
especially well not Turtles well yeah
also Turtles but more specifically
tortoise
they're the ones that are
on land
if the Oracle games were remade would
they be sold separately or bundled I
hope that it would be bundled
but if I had to guess
like in terms of money it would be more
beneficial for them to to do it do them
separately
sell them separately I should say
yeah she's scared of tortoise
[Music]
I don't remember why I just know that
whenever she sees one even in a movie
she's like
get it away oh I don't have the key
guess I cannot go here then
oh man
that's tough I don't even know how I'm
supposed to get back without taking
damage
okay okay I'm gonna die
[Music]
I hope I get rocks feathers soon
so I can jump over things
it's my first death that's way earlier
than I expected it
[Music]
because this dungeon is pretty easy
at least in terms of
enemies
it's okay I'm not going for a challenge
run anyway
[Music]
I gotta do all this again
oh it's in level three here
I think in ages it's in the first
dungeon or maybe the second one
Ah that's so unfair
the bat was just waiting for me
so there's a key in this room
[Music]
there it is I should have just gone here
first oh
[Music]
oh it's level two in ages man some
people know the game even better than
than me actually I don't know much about
Aegis anymore I know this game way
better
the last time I played Aegis is was an
eye emulator I think because I had no
other way to play it because I I don't
have a Game Boy advanced or color
anymore
mini boss
oh
can I just don't lock him
oh they both die
well I actually almost died again
I hate this saw guys I don't know what
they're called
hmm
uh sad suck
my dad has played all the Zelda games
except for these two
then he's got work to do
how
was it this one which one was it
uh
[Music]
is it can I not get in here at all
foreign
defeat something first before I can push
a block
I'm already stuck
sometimes you can only push them in a
specific Direction I think right or is
this maybe I this uh I I get out of this
place at some point
[Music]
oh it is a specific Direction really I
think I thought I'd push them
every
in every direction possible but
all right I'll make sure
oh
wait I I I didn't push it up damn
[Music]
but yeah that's a great achievement even
like the uh like Zelda 2 and stuff
because those games are hard
not to uh
not that I doubt your dad's gaming
skills but
I've never finished Zelda 2.
and I'm not planning to
oh I was reading chat
ugh
shouldn't do that
that's one of the few things I really
hate about these games is
that that would be worth a remake
actually
just map constantly having to pause it
swap items
you hit pause throughout this game so
many times
like hundreds of times I think
but you know the the
it only had two buttons so it's not like
there was any other way that the Game
Boy Color I mean only had two buttons
I don't know if it was here or the other
way
yeah I think that it is back at the
central room
let me check
I remember a b
yeah here it is
torches
[Music]
because lighters don't exist in this
universe
oh no
not floor Masters
[Music]
had the Rings
the Rings were actually kind of cool in
this game because they give you all
kinds of
like little boosts or power-ups or
change your appearance
way better rewards than korok seeds
you don't have anything to store these
fairies nah
well prepare to die
I don't know if I should use bombs or
seeds for this guy
I know he's like a oh wait it's The
Dragon
damn
he's done some lifting since now that
Zelda one
oh
damn he is almost as weak as he was in
this Zelda one though
aquamentus
classic boss
they should have put him in uh tears the
kingdom
together with glioch
[Music]
yeah the attack boost ring is good
I think there's one ring that changes
your appearance into one of those
subrosions
I always like that one
Gloom hands
yeah because Gloom hands were kind of
the uh
equivalent
of the wall masses or floor Masters
I think uh wall Masters were the worst
in Ocarina of Time the first time I I
had no idea what was going on and
suddenly a hand comes out of the sky
drops you back at the beginning of the
end of the uh of the dungeon
the beginning of the entrance that's
kind of
a weird way to say it
10 second fight yeah
do I have to go to the Temple of Seasons
first I think you just said that
that is all
but I do know where to go I think
oh yeah
hit her off her broom I think ugh
[Music]
watch it there watch where you go you're
the one flying around I'm just standing
here
Sunday driver
I can't find any long long eggs it's not
my problem
I'll just take the stuff you dropped too
we'll see about that
I got the rupee
not bad but that's all you got all you
get today
I think I got the uh I got I was on top
on that deal
oh
[Music]
okay monster measures to stream once a
week or more what you think
well that would get in the way of my
content normally that's why I normally
don't stream every week because when I
am working on stuff
animating things and
then I have to stay focused on that but
if my If I Stay like if I'm not healthy
by next month
I guess I could stream a little bit more
to to compensate
I want to at least wait until my blood
test comes in so I know even though I'm
not feeling tired anymore
I still want to know at least if there's
like some sort of deficiency going on I
don't have to be here
I can just leave town
oh yeah this guy
I'm a Wandering Prophet yeah sure
Sakura
spring summer autumn winter the four
Spirits are calling you
make no mistake
the Temple of seasons is still hidden in
this world
if you can find the temple and then pay
a visit to the spirits who what these
text boxes are so small it's like two
three words uh that's maximum that they
can display
farewell okay
or in the other one too or else my OCD
won't leave me alone I don't actually
have anything
it's a joke
uh should I go in here I think this goes
to the windmill guy yeah I don't have to
go here
well maybe just for the music one more
one one
it's cool that they put it in this game
too
[Music]
it's the end of that track
yeah I think it's just to talk to the
guy right
yeah
he's just part of the trading side quest
yeah he needs oil for his windmill
stream deserves more viewers well I'm
already happy that people showed up to
begin with I've been inactive for almost
six weeks now I guess
like my last upload was somewhere in
June
I think
which is right before I started to get
sick
it was right after my birthday that
the pain started coming in
no I thought there was going to be a
hidden
oh this
this song is so funny
this is a stealth Mission I believe and
I always fall for that one trick at the
end I'm gonna see if I will be able to
remember how and why and but there's
like this one part where she peeks out
one last time and it always gets me
[Music]
do do
what's a temple wait they don't have
temples in subrosia they don't know what
that is
without being seen yet
stealth Mission time
I gotta concentrate for this one so if
because you have to do the whole part
over again
[Music]
she's going up or down up
all right
I think it's on the third or the fourth
time I think it's this one yeah
like there's one part where she just
I always forget about it
like here look look
she always does that
all right I should say I always fall for
it of course she always does it but
every time I start a new game
I fall for it
yeah thank you John John
thanks thanks a lot
hey black links
I'm uh I'm glad you showed up anyway so
it doesn't matter if you're late or
early
a wizard never arrives late he arrives
exactly when he wants to
have you been doing
in my absence
Boomerang time yeah uh-oh do I have to
do the go the the Goron dance because
I'm terrible at that
oh
I think this goes to the
lava Springs or something
yeah cannot go here yet look at them all
chill in here
with a towel on their head
what are these creatures anyway they can
just
chill inside lava and they're totally
fine
is the Goron dance not in this game no
right
oh it's the easier version the subrosion
dance
grab items Hit Switches and stun beasts
from afar from far away
I thought he was about to call me a
boomer
they're so useful yeah give it to me
let's catch it out of the air
if you can do this erosion dance well
you get a boomerang so this guy is quite
the dancer then
if he got the
got the boomerang already
oh yeah War chunks because they don't
use rupees
it's a self-standing economy
if the rupee ever crashes these guys
will be fine
I think I don't think I have to go here
I think I need the boomerang to get to
the temple
probably
right
because there's I think there's a switch
that you you have to hit to create a
bridge
let me just check to be sure
you finally come when the temple was
buried
I thought perhaps you wouldn't come to
see me
this Temple seasons is where we four
Spirits reside
waited for a I have waited a long time
for this moment
do you like spring
or summer Well normally I like summer
the most but this year has been
pretty bad
like my health issues aside mosquitoes
everywhere the weather has been horrible
here I heard that in the south of Europe
there's like flooding and hail storms
and
like
40 degree 50 degrees scorching weather
it's just disaster after disaster and
meanwhile here it's like
of course I mean Celsius not Fahrenheit
for my American viewers
I don't know what that translates to
because I still don't know
how much Celsius and how to convert
Celsius in Fahrenheit
but yeah
oh
do I get the rod of Seasons already so
do do I need the boomerang or not or is
it optional
you got the rod of seasons
I think I do need it because you need to
charge it with one of the seasons
now bring the rod of seasons to us
season spirits in The Four Towers
I don't remember which one you get first
but I'll just go into the one
that I can get to which I do think I
need a boomerang for
is it this one no
no
heat waves are so lame yeah oh my God it
was terrible
we we started out yeah here it is we
started out with a heat wave
like mosquitoes everywhere and now
suddenly it's just rain and cold it was
actually cold today
been a terrible summer
50 Celsius is 122 Fahrenheit
well it's not like that was everywhere
but I I do believe like in some parts of
Italy they had like record high
temperatures
and now they have mud floods like flash
floods
last I checked on the news
so yeah
good luck to my Italian friends
I'm gonna buy a shovel
we take on jobs that interest us man
they have a lot of freedom to choose
then
so can I buy a shovel
no you're just going to repeat what you
said before
alrighty then
then I won't give you money
not that I have any money here
I have zero ore
should dig up the ground near here you
can get four chunks well I would do that
if you would give me a shovel
most amazing they don't have any cool
pools in the Netherlands man
what do you mean like cool pools
we do have cools but
[Music]
indoor pools are I don't know what it is
about them but I just don't like them
the smell of chloride chlorine or
whatever it's called in English
Chlor as we call it floor
uh where's the dancing thing
I know
it's the dancing thing near the pool or
man I forgot I I underestimated how much
I
forgot about this game
I've already been everywhere
yeah chlorine okay
I thought it was chloride or something
but
is there like a cave here somewhere I
can go
oh wait I can go down here
is it here yeah
and now I'm gonna fail
because this is like Simon Says kind of
like like that but with rhythm involved
In My Memory my short-term memory is not
good
my long-term memory is great
fluoride oh
they put fluoride in the water
actually they really do do that right in
America at least I think in Europe they
don't do that
because I remember seeing a clip on
Twitter from or somewhere I don't even
know if it was Twitter or somewhere else
of uh Alex Jones
you're like they put chloride in the
water
and then I looked it up and it was
actually true although it didn't have
the effects that he claimed it did like
according to him it was like
brainwashing people
yes
then join the circle
need instructions
just to be sure yes
tried to copy what I mean undo step to
the right
on that stuff
oh man this is gonna suck
Let's Dance
foreign
we're speeding up
uh you're pretty good you're one of her
best dancers today here's your prize
I got it yay
where do you stream from my office in
the Netherlands well office it's
yeah I guess it's it's my office
I have my own little office room
inside my house
so now we can do it ah thank you thank
you I really thought I was gonna fail
it's not the Rhythm that is a problem
because you know
years of playing guitar I know I do have
some kind of Rhythm at least to a
certain extent
but the
the memorizing the moves is a little bit
difficult
like the combination between the two
I don't know if we get Summer first or
spring
let's see
but it really is a fairy
like an Ocarina of Time Ferry
[Music]
child of the crested hand that sounds
like a cult
welcome child of the Crest at hand
hey arenor
yeah I do want to talk about tears of
the Kingdom but I'm currently just
playing this
because
I don't know I I wanted to play this one
because it just came out on switch and I
was happy to uh finally be able to play
it again
oh it is winter okay
oh yeah that makes sense because then
you can go across the water
in that Forest Area
[Music]
yeah tears of the Kingdom uh when it
comes to the lore I don't there's not as
much lore as I hoped there would be at
least when it came to like environmental
storytelling because you know
there's a lot of stuff that's just been
reused and
re-contextualized into something else
but it wasn't really what I was
expecting
and I personally didn't like the main
story a whole lot but
you know the gameplay is so good
that I kind of forgot about it
but it is gonna be more difficult to
come up with video ideas for tears of
the Kingdom than it is uh for than it
was for breath of wild because the whole
the the entirety of Hyrule was new
all the new buildings and new things
that you had to discover
and with tears the kingdom there's
there's you know there's the depth but
and the islands but there's not really
that much environmental storytelling
going on there
yeah I guess that's always the problem
with a direct sequel especially one in
the same Hyrule
like Majora's Mask didn't have that
problem because it's not in Hyrule
oh this guy again are you following me
I don't think they ever explain what
this guy's deal is like how he knows so
much he's just
like a lazy guide
yeah I know I know
not really
yeah yeah I know I know I know
I'm a seasoned player you know
all right
oh
it's winter
my least favorite season
I'm sure winter is great in some
countries but not here it's mostly just
gray and rain
oh
wow
I keep trying to press L to throw the
bomb
which that's not how that works that's
not how any of this works
there is no R button
I would have liked more dungeons yeah
yeah me too
it was a bit of a shame that the spirit
Temple ended up being like I didn't even
realize I was doing a dungeon
when I got there and it officially tells
you Spirit Temple I was like oh wow
there's another dungeon that's really
cool and then it was just
Rock'em sock'em robot and then it was
done
just a robot fight
[Music]
yeah that that was a bit of a
disappointment
in general the dungeons didn't really do
it for me at first I thought they were
pretty cool
at least because I did the the lightning
to yeah the lightning Tempo first
and I really liked it
the only thing I didn't like it right up
I didn't like right off the bat was the
fact that it was
like basically kind of like co-op with
one of the yeah you have to do the
dungeons with
someone else
I I was hoping to just do them by myself
oh
there we go
[Music]
I mean I can I can see many people
who do like it the the the dungeons
for me they were not like the biggest
upgrade
they were still very Divine beast-esque
they just had more unique Aesthetics
which is already a step in the right
direction
but you know Different Strokes for
different folks
the other lightning Temple was
probably the best one I did I did like
the Rito one aesthetic aesthetically a
lot as well
but it's still
just the fact that you just have to
activate things across the dungeon and
that's it
I don't know because when I first got to
the Rito dungeon I was like uh
I thought to myself well it's very much
the sand ship
it feels like the sand chip from uh but
it's like way shorter like the what was
it the Skyward Sword
it was way way shorter
I think there is a hidden passage here
somewhere
[Music]
do I have to pay him for his door
I thank you for paying to fix my door no
I burn you
I'm gonna destroy your oh wait I cannot
lift parts yet
but you know what it's okay when it
because when it comes to dungeon type
challenges and stuff
you also got a
Elder ring before that and that one had
dungeons
the way I like them
so it's not like I missed out
um
see if I can
huh
oh no this water is that it doesn't
freeze only shallow water
alrighty
noted
but yeah I guess I can already tell that
other creators also haven't uploaded as
many lore things as expected probably as
some people probably expect it
maybe also for the same reason that
there's just it doesn't have that same
mystery
as breath to Wild had because everything
was reused
but you know
maybe they will bring out one of those
books again like creating a champion and
that will explain more
because I remember the theory Community
really
utilizing that book
very very well
like a lot of iconic videos were made
after
the book came out
uh I think you can go into that cave oh
here's the dungeon itself
I think you can do something here
I'm not sure actually
[Music]
oh yeah
I guess this water does freeze
biggest mystery is probably the timeline
stuff
yeah
Dragon break is the way to go I'm I I
have no idea I'm staying away from the
timeline for now because it's
it is so unclear it feels like a remake
of Ocarina of Time like a reboot I
should say
[Music]
it really does feel like it
which was a little bit disappointing I
really thought they were going to go
somewhere
now that the timeline had been
established properly
[Music]
snakes remains
I can already tell I'm gonna use Ember
seeds here a lot
[Music]
shooting statues
they're not as bad as they are in the
original Zelda at least
well there's already a lot of forks in
the road here
actually I want to check out
I can never move forward before it
checking all the side rooms first
[Music]
timeline rarus passes after all the all
the games too
dark Nintendo crisis
now when it comes to the timeline I just
I got nothing I just for now I'm just
gonna say it feels like a like a reboot
of Ocarina of Time but it could it could
be
something else maybe they will explain
more later either in DLC or
another creating a champion like book
but for now it just it's very puzzling
I don't think anyone can defend it
definitively say what the solution is
most people just say well it's probably
a dragon break then but there's not
really like that's so ambiguous cannot
really prove whether or not it's a
dragon break or not
because
breath of wild also had the same deal
going on where there were like
references to all the games
some of them just were clearly just
Easter eggs
others were more convincing I guess
like do you count DLC as well
it's always it's always a bit tricky
I prefer to just focus on other stuff so
I'm I'm doing a video on the upheaval
because I think the upheaval is very
interesting
uh because it's not just it it doesn't
seem like the upheaval was purely
ganondorf's doing
it feels like it was also planned by the
other side the the probably the Zona or
whoever came after the Zona
because some parts of the upheaval don't
benefit Ganondorf at all
uh
I think I use this puzzle here in an
example in a video where I was like
subtle Clues are hidden and other people
are like even with subtle by subtle do
you mean that giant arrow well I thought
it was subtle
I just saw blocks first time
[Music]
lawn mowing rupees
but yeah uh
like I said some some parts
of the upheaval are clearly not
ganondorfs
uh intention at least
like the fact that some of the zonai
structures rose up uh the
the tears suddenly appearing
which was also said to have been
triggered by the upheaval
because before that they were invisible
[Music]
and there's many more of those types of
examples where it's like some parts of
the people are in ganondorfs like they
are to his benefit but other parts are
totally not like the opposite
thank you
how did that not hit
I guess because it was still bouncing in
the air or something
[Music]
I was expecting tons of videos about
tears of the Kingdom
yeah I guess at least from a lore
perspective it wasn't
as substantial as people hoped it would
be I I've talked to a few other creators
I won't name anyone by name because
you know I don't want to speak for them
but I did get the impression from quite
a lot of creators where they were like
man it's really not there's not really
as much lore
as I hoped there would be
and even the Lord that is there is kind
of like it's just
it's not as mysterious as it was as it
was in breath well like it's very
clear-cut
just this is what what happened or the
opposite there's just so little known
about it that making a theory about it
is almost impossible
like what
of course a lot of us were expecting to
see more of the zonai in this game
and we kind of did
but it still set like long after the
actual zonai aside from raru were all
just gone already
so we didn't really see their
civilization what they were all about
we just get those floating islands and
there and the floating islands also
don't really have that many things on it
it's mostly the same structures made the
same buildings
so you don't see like a city like a
abandoned zonai city or
something like that
[Music]
which uh doesn't mean the game is bad or
anything it's not like meant to be a
criticism but you know some games lend
themselves better for theorizing like
these games for example Oracle of Ages
and Seasons also
aren't really theory theorized about
that much because this story is very
clear-cut
and there's not a lot of environmental
storytelling going on there's not a lot
of big Mysteries that need to be solved
breath of the wild was just a very good
game to theorize about because there was
the giant new Hyrule with all these
buildings and
it was all post-op
post-apocalyptic so you could easily
make videos about what what was this
building about or what happened here and
how did the Great Calamity affect the
landscape or the people and
like just
you know things like fortnite and
Carla Citadel
the usual stuff
what is my favorite handheld Zelda game
um that's a difficult one
I don't know about that one
I think you have to press it yeah
[Music]
man
I really don't know
I mean these are definitely up there the
the Oracle games
just because I have great memories
I mean there's also Zelda games that are
became handheld games later like a link
to the past but I guess that doesn't
really count because it started as a
console
console title
Carla said that I was just a cave and
tears the king
yeah there's like one room where you can
get into which is actually the interior
but that's not a whole lot
what are we what's happening where's the
music oh no it's a giant face I I guess
bombs probably
I think this guy is really easy from
what I remember
he said as he get he gets hit
oh I keep forgetting that you have to
pick them up oh
[Music]
that was it okay
I guess he really was easy
yeah
do you think breath of wild is better
than tears of the Kingdom uh
my experience with breath of the wild is
I guess I would say was a little bit
better
but here's the kingdom is definitely the
better game
that I don't think because it's it's
breath wild but bigger so
it's just that breath of the wild had
the benefit that it was all new
this this whole new uh open world
approach
[Music]
but yeah like
tears of the Kingdom's mechanics and
it's more refined
but my personal experience with the game
uh I guess
breath wild felt more special maybe
that's also just because of my own life
circumstances at that time because I I
was
kind of away from video gaming for a
while I kind of lost interest in video
games in general
uh was not doing too great mentally back
then that was kind of bouncing back from
some
some life stuff
and then Brett wild came out and it
fixed
my
you know I suddenly I loved video games
again
and with their two of the Kingdom that's
not as prevalent
so when people say tears of the kingdom
is better than breath of wild yeah I
guess on a technical level that's true
but
something can still be a better
experience
or someone
oh I'm not even close to finding the
nightmare oh that's not the nightmare
key here it's just a Bosque I think
Link's Awakening it's called The
Nightmare key
let's see what people have to say
[Music]
breath of the wild had the bigger impact
on gaming that tears of the Kingdom
cannot replicate yeah exactly
that's why I said it something can still
be more something can be a worse game
purely on a technical level or something
just happens like in some ways you could
kind of compare it to
Twilight Princess as well
because Twilight Princess is an amazing
game
but it it at the time it did feel like
they were just trying to do Ocarina of
Time again but bigger
I don't think that that opinion is as
popular anymore because there's now a
whole generation whose first zelly game
was uh
yeah it was Twilight Princess I know
Hyrule gamer loves Twilight Princess a
lot and I do too
but it didn't feel as revolutionary or
special
whereas Ocarina of Time the first time I
played it I was like how is this even
possible that gaming has leaped forward
so much
oh you
freaking bad
tears of the king and added so much lore
and answered nearly all nearly zero
questions
carried over from breath wild at the
same time which was my biggest gripe
with uh tears of the Kingdom yeah I find
it kind of weird how they uh they don't
really want to acknowledge
breath of wild like the fact that it's a
sequel they don't really take advantage
of that
like so many things that were that
people who played breath while they were
in invested into the story and the lore
they kind of threw us under the bus a
little bit it's like oh all the sheikah
technology is is gone but guess what
we're not gonna explain who did it why
and when it's just all gone now it it
never existed
even though it doesn't always make sense
like I get that at some point they would
clean up all the Guardians and stuff
because
you know the Guardians are pretty
dangerous
may not want to have those lying around
anymore but why get rid of the shrine of
Resurrection
that's such a helpful because it's not
like they completely like shunned or
banned at all chica technology because
they were still doing things with it
they made a new version of the
of the Chica slave they
had all those towers and although it's
not entirely clear if they built those
Towers after the upheaval before it but
you know
it's just weird
how they don't acknowledge that some
characters remember you some characters
who you uh interacted with have no clue
who you are
it's a bit inconsistent I guess
[Music]
but like I said when a game is so great
when it comes to gameplay people tend to
forget
because I remember posting on Twitter
about it
or X I should say actually we should
just all collectively continue to call
it Twitter such a stupid name but yeah I
remember posting like that I I didn't
like the story very much
and some people for some people
apparently that was really heartbreaking
I was like whoa I mean
doesn't affect your experience of the
game right
as long as you like it it's it's uh it's
fine
oh yeah
easy solution I had time travel to your
story so you can blame it all on plot
holes like I can all blame all plot
holes on that well I mean time travel
has always been a bit wonky and in Zelda
lore
they've never to be fair a lot of media
does time travel completely wrong
I think the
pretty much the even uh even movies that
I really really like
that feature time travel like Looper for
example and uh 12 Monkeys I think was
also really really good but most of them
do it wrong
like there's always inconsistencies
[Music]
I think the only piece of media I've
ever seen that has time traveled at 100
makes sense it is darker the the German
series on Netflix
where am I going
where's the map oh there we go
oh yeah the map is not very helpful in
this
it's just squares
I should have just opened the chest
and now I'm out of bombs
[Music]
yeah I don't have enough bombs
I guess I was talking too much am I
gonna get bombs back do I have to buy
bombs from this guy
oh no
10 bombs 30 rupees yeah let's just do it
it's not like rupees are scarce in this
game
good
let me check chat before I start walking
again
yeah they could have just
uh you know I wouldn't say like
respected us but
you know serve everyone
because right now I felt like they once
again gave
preference to the fact that like they
just pretend like uh tears of the
kingdom is gonna be everyone's first
Zelda game ever
and they didn't play rest a while
and I I cannot understand that
philosophy because there's so many games
oh you have to be faster
I'll just do this while without talking
real quick
I didn't even realize there was a timer
give me more bombs
I'm gonna
become broke
[Music]
I don't like the fact that he holds it
over his head
normally it's the other way around you
place it first and then you pick it up
and throw it
there we go
[Music]
but yeah like for example uh the the
Metro series not Metroid but Metro well
even Metroid also applies to that one
like my first Metroid game I've ever
played is dread
and it's not like I couldn't enjoy dread
because I missed a lot of backstory
first of all I can just go and look up
what happened prior to that game
and even if I didn't I can still
like it still made enough sense to me
it's not like uh the whole game I'm just
like I don't know what's happening I
don't know who everyone is
like of course I do know who crate is
because he's in Smash in in the stages
in one of the state I think in norfair
or something
and it's just a name that you once in a
while you just hear about but
yeah I I could enjoy the game just fine
without knowing all the Metroid lore
so I don't don't understand why with
Zelda they always want to pretend like
the last games didn't happen or
but do a very very very very very
minimum
thank you where do I go
this dungeon is already like a huge leap
up in difficulty
uh
there has to be a place where
what did I get I got the bracelet things
is there something like way at the
beginning
Maybe
like last time there was a room almost
all the way back at the beginning of the
dungeon
[Music]
oh brinstar depths yeah that's the one
not nowhere
sorry I don't know my Metroid
although I I am thinking about picking
up the remake of prime because it just
looked great
kind of reminds me of Half-Life a little
bit which is one of my favorite
[Music]
games of all time
yeah I think there was something all the
way back at the beginning
if I use this one
there has to be a room here somewhere
that like you have to use a bottle
like it's blocked by a bottle or
something
is it here
no this is just
[Music]
let's see
yeah I never really explored this room
I just went straight through the
bombable wall I think
[Music]
oh I have been here
ah get off me
come on
did I go up here
did I no I don't think or did I
I'm so confused
yeah I have been here
primary make is great yeah is it good
it just looks really cool to me so I I
am thinking about picking it up after I
finish the Xenoblade 3 DLC because I'm
playing that one currently
I'm already pretty far I think
so I'm probably gonna finish that first
and then I'm gonna pick up remake
[Music]
I think I have to do something with that
yeah I think I know what to do
it's a very tricky uh
it's actually surprisingly tricky
dungeon sometimes
you have to make a loop I remember that
because there there's that wheel thing
I just don't know where it is
[Music]
yeah it is pretty cheap I'm surprised
they didn't just go for the full
full price again like they always do
Nintendo being Nintendo
where's that wheel
I'm getting hit way too much
here's the boss
or the mini boss I should say uh
there's a bomb of a wall here oh there's
a key block here I I got a key so
maybe it's not this dungeon then where
you have to make the loop
I remember in one dungeon doing that
what also has one of those wheels and
the only way to progress forward is to
make the wheel snap into the other
position then make a loop all the way
across the dungeon and back
foreign
a bit like the ice dungeon from Link to
the Past also requires you to do a loop
like that
all right black links thanks for
dropping by as always
you are probably my most steady one of
my most steady viewers of my streams
so thank you for that
where do I go
oh nope that doesn't connect
oh do you
bad
why does it always have to be bats
[Music]
it should be getting close to the Boston
oh there we go
boss key
oh thank you hero
much appreciated
[Music]
oh black links got got a membership
that's really awesome
welcome to the club black links so I
just got an email I had to quickly check
if it was something important
I don't think I have to push anything
here
I can
just shoot straight for the boss if I
want to
yeah this was the key door
oh I have to kill these guys again well
at least I'm gonna get new bonds but
really cool of you hero
[Music]
hey it's Moxie how have you been
uh when I think of moxie I immediately
think of hell of a boss
it's the only Moxie that I know
from fiction at least
and in real life
[Music]
no I didn't have to do the loop thing
just a very small one though
I don't think that's the one I meant
am I still sick yeah
it's not as bad as uh
like a few weeks ago but it's
still not over
like right now it's uh it's okay usually
when I focus on things and I move around
and stand uh stand around and stuff like
that then then it's
I'm doing pretty well
because as soon as I sit down for a
longer period of time I just
I just get so many like pain in my
abdomen and
I'm just I've said this a couple of
times before but at least I'm not tired
anymore
like a few weeks ago when it first
started I just wanted to sleep the whole
time like I would sleep for 14 hours per
day and still feel absolutely
just burnt out just so tired
it was really annoying
Dongo
I think I don't need my sword for this
fight so I will just
put the
bracelet on B I guess yeah
yeah I don't think you ever use a sword
thank you
oh
look at him
no
what is he doing
oh he's gonna charge
this guy is pretty pretty easy as well
unless he has like a phase two where he
just completely obliterates me
this one was even easier than acromantis
because at least aquamantis shoots like
projectiles and stuff
are you gonna be playing through the
whole game today oh no
no I do have to go to bed at a
reasonable time because a healthy
sleeping schedule is half the work of
recovering
it takes many many hours to to beat this
game
but I will play it more
especially uh if I continue to uh take
it easy for a little bit
really depends on when the symptoms the
worst of the symptoms go away
I feel so lazy that that's the worst
thing about it
because I am never sick I never have flu
I never have uh like my my immune system
is really good
[Music]
so I whenever I am sick it's either
something
like chronic because apparently it's not
IBS it's IBD
I
at least that's what my uh my fiance
tells me
just uh
bowel disease
you can finish the game in five hours
yeah if you know what you're doing
you you overestimate my power
you know since I was inactive for a
while I thought I might as well
do some streaming
[Music]
but I won't be doing it daily because
I try to stay
away from the keyboard as much as
possible
I've been playing some Counter-Strike
once in a while because it's an easy
game to just turn on play a couple of
rounds and then immediately stop again
but other than that I
I've been trying to stay active stay
moving
go for walks and stuff
you're like I'm repeating myself but
some people were not there when I talked
about it the first time but
uh
where do I go
I have to
[Music]
oh oh wait my heart's a full
oh here we go
let's go
I did notice I hit 160k subscribers so
that's pretty damn cool
I think I can
you can plant a Goshen a gacha seed
even this game is gotcha mechanics
[Music]
yeah that is pretty low for a speed run
I guess there's not that many shortcuts
to you can take with this game
monster maze would you would drinking
energy drinks with electrolytes help you
help with your crisis
I don't know I try to stay away from
caffeine uh I don't drink any alcohol
whatsoever
uh I try to eat as much fibers like as
many fibers as possible
[Music]
and just get exercise because I wasn't
exercising nearly enough
so I'm going on a run with my dog
[Music]
at least every day
except when I'm too painful but
the last few
days
slash week have been significantly
better
is this game canon because I don't
remember if it is or not yeah it's this
one is Canon it's it's on the official
uh Legend of Zelda timeline
usually you can tell uh if if a game has
the legend of prefix then it's Canon
with the exception of Zelda 2 that's the
only one that doesn't have that
but for example
age of calamity
or Hyrule warriors in general doesn't
have the pre-pick so it's not considered
Canon or maybe
Ambiguously kind of
oh this is like late game stuff the
Pirates
I don't think the CDI games have the
legend of prefix either so
I guess that rules those out too
not that that it was ever questioned if
they were Canada you know
I think I can walk across here
we did at least manage to get two
dungeons
today I don't know if I can finish a
third but
is there a reason for going here
oh yeah
absolutely there is
the 2D games I'm always happy to to find
a piece of heart because they are so
much harder than the 3D titles
would you rather have an apple or an
orange uh I'm allergic to Apple so
orange it is
actually I'm not sure if I'm allergic to
the apples themselves or the skin or the
stuff they spray on the skin but
anytime I eat an apple I get like severe
like itching in my throat it's really
annoying
can it not be winter now
can I change it back
now you can only choose one and just
hope that it will randomly change to a
different season
uh I have to go back to Horan Village
there's got to be a new route I can take
somewhere
like you can ask the maku tree
[Music]
wait you can turn off the select button
stuff
really
[Music]
uh someone says monster means aren't you
my height I'm six foot two no um you are
you are definitely taller than me I'm
like five eight five nine something like
that
I'm one of the smallest Dutch people
because we are known for being very tall
but
yeah I'm uh I'm not very tall
well I guess five nine five eight is
still considered above average in most
countries but in the Netherlands I'm
I'm an average height guy in a country
full of giants
wait who said something about you can
you can get rid of the the bar at the
bottom
I remember it reading it some oh here
Danko
[Music]
I don't know how to pronounce that name
but
you can actually turn that off
because it is very annoying also for my
captures I always
have to crop them out
I thought I thought it was just
permanently there
you know I need neat rocks
better for that one
it's got to be a new passage yeah here
it's pool swamp eyeglass Lake
I'm guessing we don't go to the lake for
now
yeah rocks feather which someone said
was in the third dungeon so that makes
sense
what's this place all about
chickens
yeah like stealing your chicken oh
I guess not
whoa
whoa we have two new chickens
by the way in real life I mean
one of them looks like a
like genuinely looks like an eagle
at least her head does
[Music]
choose which animal companion you would
not well I always
thought Ricky was the the coolest
[Music]
because he has boxing gloves but uh
mooch is pretty cool too
I got him during my very first
playthrough I remember that
he is helpful
hey gossip Geist
wait where do I know know that name from
do you make your own content too
I think I
I've seen one of your videos
pretty sure I did
because I do watch other people's Zelda
stuff
not every one of them because that that
would take ages but
[Music]
yeah you do see I I
remembered oh no do I have to pay this
guy again
oh no oh he gave me money
I have nothing more for you well you
have done your job sir
thank you so much
even though I broke your door
you are a lot cooler than your twin
brother
foreign
I don't remember which video it was I
saw from you but
because it's it was a while ago
but I do remember seeing it
I remember your logo
I didn't know you were a member but
that's really awesome
always good to see fellow creators
I want to check everywhere
oh it was worth it at least I killed one
of them
I hate these guys
they always managed to get a hit in
before you kill them
you lose your Shield to a leg like I
don't have a shield
I didn't know you actually you had to
buy one
or if you just get one oh send seeds
[Music]
foreign
I will just continue then
awesome Mario and Luigi brothers you
make Zelda videos too
well everyone just go check it out then
[Music]
the more content we have about Zelda the
better
[Music]
oh
where did there's a guy like training in
here
I'm I'm the legendary champ blano
you want some
and then earn it in the ring
ah
I think I'm gonna get destroyed but yeah
sure
we trade punches
until one of us gets knocked out of the
ring
and no items
if you break the rules once
the next match is for 20 rupees damn
that's steep
and no rings only Fists
oh man I'm gonna get
I'm just mashing oh
what a horrible range
I think you have to wait for him to do
something
oh I'm gonna get knocked out oh
it's hard to know when to hit him
oh A and B both punch okay
okay
I got I got whacked
if you're mad tell it to your fists
I'm good I don't think you get anything
anyway
I'll try again later
or not oh all my items are gone
uh
cut down some flowers
stick the jab onto me
there's almost no range uh no range on
your punches so I I really don't know
how to how it works
but I don't think you have to
do anything
I don't even know what the reward is but
oh my God
[Music]
there we go
uh yeah there were there was nothing
there down there I think
Far Far East Sunken City
it's far trying to find a ride uh that's
probably referring to
one of the animal friends
uh
nope
oh this is not the place I want to be
that's I think that that's to odax's
Castle
what would you like to see in the next
Zelda game
[Music]
um
good question Teddy
I don't know
I really don't know oh hey there he is
I guess something just completely new
like
I don't know about mechanics because
Nintendo will do what they do best and
give us something we didn't know we
wanted
[Music]
but I just want to have a Zelda game
again where it's not set in Hyrule
because those tend to stick out quite a
lot I don't I don't want to go through
the whole motion once again new Hyrule
new
like the same story again basically
I'd like to see a 3D cell that it takes
place in a completely different land
because there's so much more to the
world than just Hyrule
do you like to use the kingdom yeah sure
I do
[Music]
important question when you download
ages and seasons are they permanent or
you need to maintain your online
subscription I heard that the games are
removed sometimes even with subscription
I have no idea I really have no idea I'm
just happy I can play them right now but
yeah
I I have no idea
if if anyone can
Enlighten us both Isaac and me
none of my games have ever disappeared
nor have my save game so
I guess we're good
[Music]
oh no
I do have to beat that guy
he got his boxing gloves stolen
[Music]
so I do have to go back to that guy
but how can I beat him he's too good his
moves are incredible
uh
this was to the Onyx Castle this was too
far Far East which also says get a ride
okay this is late later later in the
game
I must have read over your comment so
[Music]
I thought it was just gonna be for a
piece of heart or something
Monson is I like your Zelda maker idea
like the Mario Maker game yeah there's a
few games out there that already kind of
do that like Super Dungeon maker and I
think there's another one being made
right now and then there's also
are not RPG Maker the other one all
right I always forget what it's called
there's another big one
[Music]
oh
so is amp just both the same Punch or is
it
[Music]
like
oh I got away
oh you just
easel and it looks like I can only hit
him from the
from the side
oh there we go
I have to give him a good old one two
left right
[Music]
yes
what's my favorite Zelda game uh I don't
really have a favorite I just have like
a top five that constantly changes but
damn
that lightning effect is very very
look
stress inducing with the whole screen
flashes
ages would probably be mine ah
very nice
it's a great game both both are great
games
there's something just very nostalgic
about these old graphics
if they never get remade I would be fine
with it but I do get that
some people would like to
see them remade
I prefer if that time goes into a new
today's holiday game but
I haven't got my subscription yet a bit
tight on cash oh well that then you
definitely have to prioritize
[Music]
okay
I got Ricky's flute
take the spool swamp get in my pouch
yeah I'm riding a giant kangaroo
who shoots tornadoes on it out of his
fists
I can clear one hole easily
give it a try
[Music]
you better you are kangaroo
Ricky's really cool
look at him he just punches everything
punch that flower yeah
screw you and screw your flowers
ow
I have to make sure there's nothing
secret here
oh
oh no is he gonna give me money or do I
have to pay up
what do you think
clock says my name uh my my dog's name
is also Ricky oh that's a cool name for
a dog
mine is called Dino
yeah I gotta pay up
wow quite a lot too
well sir you're gonna get a jar to the
head and another one
and one more for good measure there you
go
geez
what's over here
nothing
oh
I forgot B is getting out
see what's inside here
hello ma'am
oh it's so hot even sitting by my prized
soothing pool doesn't help
I need something okay Trading questing
wow that was not suing at all
we actually hurt you oh no Rick you've
gone
now I have to blow the flute
where did he go
there he is
Cliff like this one like that one
just jump if you move up to it give it a
try
hook
let's punch him crows
what does the sign say can I read it
while I'm
nope
Farm ruins spools exactly we're going to
a school swamp course
cannot pick those up
Pegasus seeds
instead of Pegasus boots we have seeds
foreign
how do you make your YouTube pictures
you mean thumbnails
uh depends like from my streams I'm very
lazy I'll just grab some artwork but for
my uh
for my videos it's just
whatever I feel like the video needs
sometimes I'll have a 3D model that I
that I did
yeah I thought he said I I think climb
up or jump up Clips because this one's
too high
all right
but yeah sometimes I'll have a 3D model
or if something else I made
that I can use other times I have to use
official artwork and spice it up a bit
I don't really have a set format for my
thumbnails it's it's whatever whatever
like every video is a happy little
accident
things just
falling